hello everyone welcome back to the
podcast today we have a very special
guest mrs. mrs. Appel that guy oh yeah
what do I call you what's the right
thing as mrs. okay I mean I've never
really been asked that but yeah Senora
don't call me I just
Stacy wait Stacy Diaz apodaca or Stacy
DS oh yeah it is Stacy there's a Buckeye
but your middle name is Kim right yeah
yeah okay that was just like something
like no girl all right you better work
yes no in Mexico everybody has to last
night I grew up with them and up until I
was 13 so I just yeah I decided to
embrace them and I'm Stacy as a Bukka
yeah well the rest of the roster here is
myself Jessica myself Tiffany Beau's our
favorite our favorite down there on the
end our little firecracker so I just
want to suck up to her right now I'm
just showing you some love you know
we're working through some personal
stuff we're all trying to give each
other love but anyways today I thought
it would be a great idea to talk about
getting back with your ex is that a good
idea or is there ever an instance where
that's okay can I am I allowed to know
so I mean have any of you guys ever
considered or tried getting back with an
ex so me and this [ __ ] oh my god
my worst acts of all time and that's the
one you decided to keep getting back
with yeah it's always that way always
and like there was a point and I
remember my mom never let me forget this
where she told me it was after our
fourth breakup no it was out of date how
long did you guys last one each leapin
last a year oh I mean the whole
relationships we did not even hear broke
up got back together broke up got back
together and I
member crying - my mom and I sold her oh
my god it's like arguing with myself
yeah and it was the words I'd pick
somebody that was so similar to me like
they didn't compliment me they didn't do
anything it's like because he was like
me it felt comfortable but when two
people are too similar it's just not
it's actually really not good or at
least in my experience yeah yeah I think
a lot of the time so you keep going back
to the X now because he's so similar to
you or because you know it's special but
because we're so used to toxicity and
the toxic country yeah its comfort you
know it said a lot I mean we're jumping
real deep real soon but it said it very
oh yeah I'm taking you there it said
very often that whichever way you up
like your parents you know whatever you
saw in your parents is what you're used
to so a lot of times we keep getting
back with that toxic ex because even if
we're not aware of it he or she reminds
us of that familiarity we had in our
parents so you try to fix a narrative
with this new person that your parents
couldn't work out kind of like if my
parents got divorced because my dad was
a piece of Shi T I'm gonna go get a guy
that's just like him to try and fix it
and fix and narrative that my mom really
crazy I think also to there is that that
talks is the comfort of the not toxicity
because you think I deserve this yeah
that person I deserve this and so then
hurting you is okay because I genuinely
believe that that's what you deserve
yeah sometimes I think that may not be
conscious though yeah because I it's not
a cyclical kind of like Groundhog Day
relationship like you wake up and it's
the same Oh [ __ ] and then you put up
with it and you start all over and do it
all over again yeah I never in the
middle of those types I never felt like
I deserved it but looking back it's like
oh you subconsciously thought that's
what you deserve because otherwise you
wouldn't have stayed like so even if you
don't realize it honey something is is
holding you back making you think you
deserve that yeah yeah I liked about
yeah sometimes it's straight-up abuse
yeah and you don't label it as abuse you
just don't you know I think I've even
had
situations where I've heard one of my
friends be like well my mom put up with
it so I should be just as much of a
woman if not then how am I not like how
am i letting my family down or what are
my parents going to say or what are my
do stairs over there back in Mexico
gonna say where they're like miles away
but you're trying to live up to their
standards
- now fail them you know it's it's
really that definitely probably comes in
when you're an older relationship like
mid-20s and going into your 30s and
stuff but like for girls that are maybe
still in high school or early college
like what kind of experiences can we
share for them because I feel like it's
probably a ton of girls right now or
even guys listening or watching to this
podcast that are thinking right now I
just want to text my ex I just want to
make it all go away I wanted to go back
to the way it was like what do we wanted
to say to them because I feel so bad for
you guys that right now that are
probably going through that like what's
your best do you actually I mean just
you just got out of a breakup are you
going through that she's like high
school girls but me really know
sometimes you feel like you want to hit
him up
sometimes yeah like when the breakup
first first happened I was like thank
God I was really like so done cuz it was
it was five years it was so long and I
was just so sick of [ __ ] but now a lot
of it yeah but right now like I guess
maybe it's the holidays playing tricks
on me everyone can relate to that yeah
everyone can relate to it and I'm just
thinking like oh I saw him the other day
he's lost weight like he looks like he
did when we first met instead of the fat
guy that he'd be killed
I just want to point out like all of us
see Joe and none of us are thinking like
oh he looks so good actually
people are grabbing clips right now
sending him to jail Joe no I mean right
get him back if I really wanted to he's
like the one dislike is Joe Joe's gonna
have like 20 like spam accounts talking
[ __ ] about me yeah so no I I think it's
just a part of the process of breaking
up and sometimes you don't want to face
the process and like the emotional kind
of journey that you have to go through
and you finally you know realize that a
person's not for you it's easy to want
to like keep things the same you people
don't like believe it is it's very so
much easier to stay in a relationship
that's not going well and probably Note
will never go well because we're adapted
to keeping things the same we like
stability but and that you know that's
really helping me right now I'm like
anything that I'm thinking I'm like oh
it's just first ability yeah it's really
not because you know when you're in the
middle of that breakup and you [ __ ]
hate that person you're like I can't
wait to be done with your ass
like why a month later has that changed
really why it's not because they've
changed or you've changed or the
circumstances of the relationship has
changed just because now you're sad
because you don't know what's coming
well you you feel confused because to
use your relationship as an example five
years ago you were a completely
different person yeah I was and you know
by your one your two your three you've
really changed and by year five you're
like a whole new person absolutely times
at the age and the experiences so this
is your first year being this version of
Jess yeah and now you're navigating it
all alone you don't have that support
system that you have or just that
familiarity yeah and it's kind of scary
because it is easier to go back to the
things where it's easy to go back to
what was comfortable yeah and that's
like you know I think that's been a
frequent problem in my life not only in
breakups that I only recently kind of
made it through was looking for that
comfort wanting to just be okay in that
comfort that's why sometimes when you
are in like an abusive relationship and
I don't mean like you know like our core
I mean like even just emotionally
abusive everything starts out good and
then it slowly gets more emotionally
abusive than anyone realizes yeah it's
just a very a little tiny percentage
each day until finally you're basically
at rock-bottom but it's comfortable yeah
because you you walk down these stairs
together and now you're at the bottom of
the stairs in it it feels good you don't
want to walk back up alone right you
know yes that was my metaphor oh I was
even gonna say I think a lot of times it
doesn't even have to get to the point of
a batterer relationship where you're at
quote unquote rock-bottom it gets to the
point where how many people can relate
like you're like well he's not even that
bad he is actually a good man yeah he's
faithful he's a hard worker I mean Joe
was all of those Joe's ever I think
Joe's everything creative that you could
think and so you think to yourself isn't
it just easier to stay with this person
like why do I have to start all over
again he's not that bad yes he's
annoying but they're all annoying
honestly they are shade auntie yep but
like it just kind of makes you wonder
like why do I have to start all over
with someone else and it's like
everyone's gonna have something wrong
I'll just stay where I'm at right and
that's honestly like what keeps a lot of
people in the place because then like
they're that idea of like no matter who
you're with you're gonna have your
problems with with the baggage right
every cuz everyone has baggage so
everyone so my question is what made you
leave or for you guys what made you
finally say like now for those
relationships where we obviously say
like you have to leave like you're
getting beat up you're getting
emotionally abuse but for the ones that
were like not that bad but you deserve a
little better what makes you finally say
you know what I can be back with this
person no matter how much I try for yeah
go ahead start we'll start there move
over here because I'm being like I
haven't even really processed the answer
yes I think I'm just gonna kind of like
talk it out is that like I was so
defeated I like
after a while I felt my own life force
being sucked away yeah
my day was no longer mine my I was a
slave to the arguments that were
inevitable isn't gonna start at 11:00
a.m. or is he gonna start at 8:00 p.m.
I mean daily and I couldn't get anything
done
I couldn't even navigate my own thoughts
and I couldn't imagine waking up and
doing this every day like I want to get
up and I want to exercise or I want to
go to my friend's house and not have to
leave because I'm getting yelled at
because I did something wrong again yeah
um I felt like my own life was being
taken away from me and I had to go and
you know each time he would come back we
broke up four or five times I mean holy
[ __ ] this guy I there was one time that
I broke up with him and I was like I'm
free yeah I am free and I remember
sitting down on my computer and saying I
know I knew for a fact that I was done
yeah [ __ ] two hours later this guy
calls me I'm not kidding y'all about to
laugh and he said I just got shot and he
told me I went to go sell this xbox in
Norfolk and the guy robbed me and shot
me oh my mom's coming I'm on my way to
the hospital and we were like 22 and
well he was just shot I have to go back
I mean and this was great but he never
let me visit him in the hospital blah
blah blah he had my attention again and
we were back together and then we dated
for another two months until on New
Year's he got mad at me because we were
on this trolley we had taken a vacation
together got in this hotel room together
and we were drinking and we were on this
trolley headed somewhere and a guy on
the trolley who was with his like wife
or girlfriend asked me a question I
responded and I made a joke with him
because I was like very personable he
was so [ __ ] pissed the argument
spiraled out of control I wanted to go
home and so he intentionally went up to
this brick wall and started hitting his
elbow along the wall he like broke his
elbow so that I couldn't leave because
he basically told me I had to take care
of him
so beat down by that that is abused yeah
100%
nobody hurt himself that's mental abuse
oh my god yeah and he told me that I
couldn't leave and I I stayed there that
yeah you know cuz I felt like I had to
take care of him
and but I think also he took advantage
of the fact that if I felt like I had
purpose I felt like I had to take care
of this is so [ __ ] up but like I I
felt like I had to take care of him and
I had to like nurse him back to like a
little project yeah and it made you
finally leave then he called me Mommy
the last drop because that [ __ ] broke
the spell yeah I was like something is
wrong here yeah this guy he was he was
really really attractive yeah it was
popular he had money you like you didn't
talk a whole lot but he talked he was
cool like everyone thought this guy was
[ __ ] cool bro he called you mommy and
I have a sexy way it was crazy I mean
[ __ ] insane my shoes yeah but you
know what's funny is like what's really
big there is there was blatant abuse and
I just told you guys summoner sounds
blatant abuse and I I [ __ ] didn't see
it or I didn't jump on it either I
thought I deserved it or or or I felt
like it gave me purpose something
something something and the thing that
snapped me out of it when I was like are
you [ __ ] your mom yeah I was like why
would you say it I think you know about
it just be stuff what you told us like
him hurting himself to get your
attention him saying like hey I'm at the
hospital to get your attention those are
all things that a kid would do like oh
my god yeah like I'm crying take her
emotionally-stunted so he had all this
facade all this like all these clothes
money at this nice ass Lexus buy me
anything do what I like whatever he
would dress me I remember he took me
shopping on time and spent like a G and
in Virginia
you spent a shopping that's a [ __ ]
lie and so all of that looks so good but
underneath it he was a child yeah a
child yeah that's crazy that's mine I
think for me
I know has been the only relationship
I've had that was healthy enough you
know not to yeah there's things that
weren't healthy about it but it was it
was a generally healthy relationship and
the first time where I broke up and
didn't fight to get it back I think yeah
it's been the first time and it's crazy
because it's been the most healthy most
I guess it's it's helped my life more
than anything being with him has changed
my life and very positive positive ways
being with him but it's it's strange
because like this most beneficial
relationship of my life I was able to
walk away from so much easier than all
of the destructive ones and that's
strange do you feel like you just grew
out of it yeah yeah I really really did
like now you see like okay I could get
this that is Joe that is like so great
for me but I know there's something else
like something missing I think the the
love that he did give me it definitely
helped me to love myself and then to
realize that like there's not I don't
want to say that I could do better than
Joe but I think it's just that like I
need to do what's more suited to me yeah
yeah and I think it's for him
yeah I mean like I don't think either of
us it's like oh I can do so much better
it's just like we need to find the
matching person and and we were able to
come to terms with that and so that's
what made this breakup a lot easier than
any other one I've ever had yeah but a
lot of my past ones were just so
dramatic and like I thought I was gonna
die like I can you know I would go back
and forth just for a whole year trying
to get back with the same guy breaking
up and getting back together and it's
just it wastes so much time of your life
yeah well I don't know if it's a
complete waste cuz overall you end up
learning from it and growing from it
yeah I don't know I didn't say it's a
waste but it does look like a waste
especially if it's like years of like
the same [ __ ] and it's like yeah
well also like if you're in college or
you're like trying to like further your
career or like as you're still growing
up and like still trying to get to the
point where you're like a stable adult
but you're wasting time instead of in
college like doing what you're supposed
to be doing you're like spending all
this time on this dude who's at the end
of the day like he's not gonna take care
of you he's not gonna be your husband
he's just wasting all of your time I I
guess I did to kind of say that point
like in my mind the first thought was
like well I have time yeah like I'll
make time because when I was in that
situation like
I was working I was in school but I was
so in love I didn't give a [ __ ] like
honestly and it's so sad because you're
wasting your time in this relationship
but I can say that had I not gone
through that relationship that was like
what I can kind of say like I can relate
to what you guys are talking about I
wouldn't be Who I am today you know and
I wouldn't have learned the lessons that
I learned and when I was going through
it it was very short-lived like yours
was too but it was so intense
oh and it's almost like okay here's this
little packet but it's so full of love
that when I open it I know it's gonna
[ __ ] explode in my face
but I don't care no I don't care because
the three days that I'm with him like
let's say after we broke up and we got
back together the three days that I see
him are so full of like I don't want to
say love like in my mind I thought it
was slow at the time but it was like
excitement passion yeah like like hot
and cold like you know what was going on
that like that hi I would literally come
home and cry to my sister and just be
like I love him so much and my sister
she's my best friend and she would be
like is this worth it to you like I look
at you right now like you're literally
crying like you're this bad [ __ ] who's
[ __ ] praises to the Internet like
that you they should love themselves and
look at how this guy has to you like do
you want to see him again and I really
like yes I love it you know and it
wasn't until I had enough and it was
years you guys like I had a boyfriend
Simba tween this guy like and I was
treated right but there was something
like something holding me there almost
like a string that I couldn't cut I
literally had to go to therapy yeah yeah
I went to therapy and I was like what
the [ __ ] do I do like I don't know what
to do and I remember my therapist she
was like she was like why did you walk
in here today and I was like well I just
wanted to tell you that I love him you
know and then she's like well why did
you make the different like why did you
make something different today well
maybe walk in through the door and I was
so I was like I don't know [ __ ] like
I'm just barely here like barely
breathing just take my money Alyssa
and she was like you walked in here
because you're ready to let him go
right she's like and literally we did
this exercise and I was like I don't
want to let him go though and she's like
you're in here you're gonna let him go
you know so a lot of times like when you
say things like well I was ready to let
him go like I wanted to let him go
because I knew it's not what it's what
it's what's best for me like there's
some of us in high school in college in
our late 20s that are like oh I didn't
want to but I had to because it was no
longer healthy for ya right you know
speaking of love we got to give a quick
shout-out to our sponsor third love yeah
I'm actually wearing my third love right
now and I would show you but pro bridge
but anyway so third love is this a great
new bra that I recently got and it
honestly fits me so perfect and that's
because I took the fit finder quiz that
find your perfect fit in 60 seconds and
they also show you different breasts
shape site and sizes and like different
types so I found out that I had like a
bell shape breast which I just imagined
them yeah and so like I said third love
helps you find and identify your breast
size and shape and finds the styles that
fit your body returns and exchanges are
completely free and they're super easy
because they deliver it to your house
and if they don't fit you and you want
to return it you can put put it in the
same box and send it back and but I
promise you you're not gonna be doing
that because it's a perfect fit like I
legit wear this bra every day and I have
to third love bras but this one that I'm
wearing in particular is my favorite so
anyway so third love knows that there's
a perfect bra for everyone so right now
they are offering our listeners 15% off
your first order so go 2/3 love.com
slash b tch now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love.com slash b tch for
15% off today yeah our next sponsor is
care of ladies would you like to tell me
a little bit about care of what y'all
it's time to get back into a healthy
routine and I want you to do it in the
most low-maintenance way possible go
online to the care
website fill out this survey about what
are you concerned about is it mood is it
your sleep is that your hair is it your
skin answer the questions and Carib will
send you this really cute package it's
like a little box that you can just set
up and you pull out your packages each
morning mine say hi Bo's oh yeah yeah
Ilia twelve calcia with me whatever they
look whatever they set me up with I
don't know all these ingredients I don't
know what all this stuff is I was like
fix this this this this and Carib was
like girl I got you yeah I also can't
express enough how high-quality the
ingredients are I always used to take a
multivitamin each day make it super
simple but when I started getting this
customized set I decided to try it and I
felt different I actually felt different
so did I have more energy
bro after my second pack I was like was
I missing some nutrients I genuinely
felt I think because b12 is in my
package I felt a lot sharper mentally I
they're really fantastic my second my
second and third-order
I paid for please give me more but yeah
so it's super easy and convenient for
50% off of your first care of order go
to take care of calm and into the code b
tch 50 again for 50% off if daddy let me
write his hat off write that down
50% off year I did not use the code and
also show us support again 50% off your
first order of care I'm gonna take care
of that cough and enter the code b tch
50 all right well welcome back to I'm
one dumb [ __ ] well so um I know we've
been super kind of negative with getting
back with your ex do you guys feel like
there's any point in time we're getting
back with your ex is okay could
potentially
be healthy could lead to a great turnout
because I know so many guys and gals are
probably thinking but this is my
situation so different like my yeah than
yours Oh [ __ ] I promise you we're gonna
work it out just kidding you know it
could be because I've actually heard and
I feel like this has happened maybe two
times in just the past couple of months
of stories where somebody broke up or
got a divorce and their 20s and in their
40s they came back together ready for
each other at that age they would turn
enough there was some deep deep
connection and you guys had to go out
there explore see what was out there and
you already know what that person is
like and as you get older I think that
we actually almost even have the ability
to strip away that negative and remember
what that good was yeah and when you see
them again literally 10 to 15 years
later like I think you know but I feel
like that's probably not the answer that
y'all were looking for you're like
should I get back there appeai don't
know on that point I guess the thing is
I think most of us might agree there if
there is a chance of getting back with
your ex it probably shouldn't be the
next month any I would say you need a
way to year kind of grow grow five years
yeah maybe a year a couple years at
maybe five years like I think that the
the point that happens because I don't
want anyone thinking like well I'm in
this situation and it worked out there's
always an exception to the rule of
course so if you're the exception to the
rule and it worked out for you
congratulations that's not the majority
of people yeah I think that I don't like
to tell people like oh it's gonna work
out in the future
because you're stealing yourself the
opportunity to truly fall in love with
someone in the process and you're like
thinking ahead and say like telling to
yourself like oh I just gotta wait till
I'm 40 I gotta wait till I'm 35 like I'm
just gonna make me with this guy for now
and not waste my time but I know that
the toxic man will come back for me you
know so I think there's a yes it can
happen but it almost has to happen
organically where you don't even yeah we
can stay here in 20 years you'll get
back it's like it's gotta fall back into
place you have to go through a
metamorphosis as a person you change you
change you change they change they
change and then you have to still kind
of fall back together but you don't want
to be thinking ten years yeah I'd be
back yeah and it really is that whole
like once you have that time apart
you're able to like you said go through
your own metamorphosis both of you go
through that and then if you guys do
reconvene it it needs to be like a
square one like clean slate like don't
carry the baggage from your really
taught me a person yeah yeah because
then it's just not even fair to approach
that that new experience with the same
person while you're still carrying
everything else from the past because
you're never gonna get over that at that
point and you're just gonna end up
falling back in the same spot so you
know I think it also is really important
to remember that it takes a lot to get
to the point where you guys break up
it's yeah it should be there's some
people like they get in one argument
they're like we're broken up well they
should just not be any yeah they should
not be in relationship that means
they're not ready to never be a threat
yeah yeah relationships I had security
enough three well use where you feel
safe yeah what they where they feel safe
and it should not be dangling over your
head exactly and if you're a person that
has been in relationship or you have
been that person that has used a breakup
as a threat you're damaging your
relationship every single guy on edik a
massive level but for people that aren't
doing that when you actually go through
a breakup you're thinking it you're
talking to people you're letting people
know what's up it takes a lot to other
those words I think we should take a
break so when that finally does happen
you have to give yourself credit that it
took a lot to get to this point and it's
like do you really want to take that all
back in a month just for that comfort
and security that we spoke about yeah or
do you want to spread your wings and get
out there and see what's up
yeah true that's what I was going to say
cuz you're talking to like the grown
version of me but if you were talking to
23 24 year old right I would be like yes
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] what do we say
what do we say to our younger selves to
get through that or I think personally
if I could talk to like younger Stacey D
which you know like I do these
exercises where I write to myself you
know I all I can do is forgive her
because what how does she know any
better she was doing the best she could
she wasn't gonna listen yeah and it's
the same thing we could tell everybody
watching right now who is in the same
situation you're gonna go through
whatever you have to go through and you
just can think to like oh I'm gonna
avoid pain like I watched you so now I'm
not gonna go through that because I went
through it you're on your own journey
and you kind of just have to know that
it'll pass if you work towards it
passing cuz there's people who get like
stuck in this cycle for years years like
50-year old women who are with the same
like [ __ ] LOI man now and they still
think he's like the greatest thing ever
you know so I really am a strong
believer of like whatever you are going
through you're meant to go through that
because it's meant to make you a
stronger person at the end of the day
and it's meant to make you learn from it
so no matter what you're going through
like like you said say see like it will
pass you just have to be strong enough
to get yourself through it yeah and once
you're out on the other end you're gonna
look back and you're gonna say look that
made me stronger I just said like yes
[ __ ] like an amigo so I just I felt it
in my soul because we're here right now
and we're telling you like you know what
yeah you're gonna go through it don't
worry it happens you'll come out alive
but [ __ ] when you're going through it
oh my god yeah they're not gonna go
through it like it feels like a roller
coaster and you don't like roller
coaster and there's like no tracks like
I think you're just sliding yeah and
you're just gonna Clio and die like it
feels like it's lasting forever and it
feels like why does it why is this
happening to me why do why and it's like
don't worry yes trust and you're in that
situation just know like all [ __ ] like
I'm just in this roller coaster and just
keeps going down not now no not at all I
mean I definitely felt that in my
younger relationship so like I just felt
like if if he leaves me it's over like
I'm never gonna find someone else that
like clicks with me
never gonna find someone that liked it
that brings this passion out of me like
everyone else is boring and lame and
like you know an imagined being in those
situations and then adding having a kid
yeah I think about that all the time of
you to the girl I've been through it
yeah I think like when you're trying to
tell someone like oh you shouldn't get
back with your ex or whatever but then
there's complications of Family and
Children and stuff like the the advice
and the leeway gets a little bit more
tough because they have to think not
only about themselves
what would you say TIFF I mean you had a
horse like what if you got I know he's
about to be told but yeah man it was the
hardest thing ever because like with me
and his dad for example like I we broke
up when Isaac was nine months old but I
was trying to get out of that
relationship a lot sooner than that and
it was just really tough because back
then like I was dirt poor like I was
just so broke I actually had to survive
off a welfare in order to like like
stand on my own two feet and it was the
toughest thing ever but in the end like
I just saw the weight like the situation
I saw the type of household that we were
creating for him and I just really saw
like I I'm not gonna be happy Isaac's
not gonna be happy he's not happy like
his dad and it's just like why are we
gonna all be in this situation just for
convenience and ultimately like I just
reached my breaking point because it was
like on and off between me and him and
especially because of the fact that we
had a kid so it was it was it was the
struggles man and we were both so young
and so immature but it just took a lot
to really walk away and just find my own
happiness with my son I mean it wasn't
even like I was able to fully be by
myself a long time either because at the
time my best friend at the time who was
a guy we ended up like finding comfort
in each other because he had gone
through a breakup around the same time
too and so it kind of I didn't even have
a chance to really see like grow myself
as a just a single like woman I didn't
even give myself that chance because
right
Gately after Isaac's dad like about a
month or two of a buffer time that's
when me and my ex I ended up getting
together and that relationship lasted
three years to a point where we got
engaged and it really got tough because
he really would use Isaac against me and
like really manipulate me to continue to
be with him because he kind of would say
like well who's gonna love you you're
just you're a single mom like who else
is gonna take you and your son and so it
was really rough and but for that
relationship it just got even I like
honestly like for me it just got to a
point where I detached emotionally where
I longer was in love with that person
and like the more I saw them
manipulating me the more angry I would
get and I'm just like no you're not
gonna win this and yeah sure you
proposed to me in public and I felt like
I was cornered and I couldn't say no and
so I said yes and like I just got myself
deeper and deeper in a situation I
didn't want to be in but in the end like
I like it got so bad I was just like I'm
I can't be with you I can't marry you
I'm gonna move to San Diego to get away
from you because like I keep getting
manipulated to continue to be with you
and it was just the most toxic thing
ever and I finally like there was just
one day when I was talking on the phone
with my aunt who lives in San Diego and
she was like make out what are you doing
like do you really want to marry this
guy like look how unhappy you are like
you want your son like look at the
relationship you left with your son's
dad and like you're in a similar
situation now like girl when are you
gonna learn your lesson kind of thing
and I was just like bi you're right I
can't do this I can't and so like I just
there was one situation where I'm just
seeing the way he reacted to that
particular situation that was like the
straw that broke the camel's back right
like or what is it yeah yeah so I was
just like okay that's it like I cannot I
this is not gonna work no matter how
much I want to fool myself and no matter
how comfortable the situation is and I
just can't do this and I gotta I gotta
think about myself Lucy you went all the
way through it to then find the strength
so like you took a long time and you
went through so much but eventually you
found your strength but one thing I'm
thinking is like bringing up your auntie
calling you like so we've all been the
person like kind of getting back with
their xtube
then like dealing with your friends and
like your close friends your close
family like there you see them going
through this and you like want to give
them help it's kind of like how do we
help someone that doesn't seem to be
able to help themself or like how do you
bring broach that subject how do you
like help someone Stacy look like you
got something to say I just feel so in
the moment I forget happy all the time
something will happen and I'm like the
person continuing to speak but I'm like
situation huh yeah I guess okay so what
I was gonna say like before even that
question yeah is like hearing all of you
speak all of you got to the point where
you went through it went through it went
through it and then one day you just
were like you know what [ __ ] it I've had
enough yes okay like that's it up until
this line I'm not crossing the line you
know so when you asked that question
it's very interesting because it's very
close to my heart
I guess it showed in my face right so
I'm a very honest friend and I obviously
love my friends and I want the best for
them now what I think is the best for
someone and like with you what I think
is the best for you and what you think
is the best for yourself maybe two
different things
so I can try to tell you let's pretend
with the Jo situation if you were trying
to get back with him but I didn't think
that was a good idea and I told you look
Jess he's this he's that you did you
were this way you were that way I don't
think it's the right thing and you were
trying to convince me otherwise there's
literally nothing we can do as your
friends until you get to that breaking
point yeah and that is silly
is it worth still having those hard
conversations with your friends though
cuz I think part of that kind of helps
them get to where they can see you even
if they don't do it right away and they
start to become an [ __ ] where they
keep asking for advice you're not taking
it but it's part of the step right yeah
that's cool so I kind of write like the
same guy was talking about the crazy guy
I forgot like yeah the mommy thing was a
turning point but it turned the gear in
my head and it reminded me of something
in that relationship so there was a
point where I was home and I
we had kind of broken up I broken up
with him after that and he came to my
house and I lived with my parents at the
time and he was banging on the door
banging on the door I told my little
stepsister I was like don't answer the
door
you might called my mom my dad I was
like he's here he's outside he's
freaking out who what a crook he started
going into our trashcan and taking trash
out and rolling it everywhere in our
front yard in our back yard he was in
the back yard banging on the door and I
had to call my I had to call my dad and
my dad was like give me his number
that [ __ ] left he left after
that call but still I felt something in
my heart like I I felt like I was like
there's there's even 20% of me and if he
gets that I could go back so what I
actually ended up doing was I went on
Facebook I went on Facebook them and
know I very publicly said almost
everything that he had done to me Wow
very publicly and I I did it because I
did realized it I had so much shame he
hit me once but it wasn't like that that
serious but it was like there's enough
that he would call me the n-word like he
wasn't black no and he was calling you
yeah yeah tell me like that this is why
my mom told me not to date Oh I would
take that you know but here's the thing
nobody in my life knew this was going on
yeah I was so ashamed I didn't tell
anybody I never told anyone because I
knew that they would tell me to get out
yeah and I didn't want ready for some
reason and so when everything was said
and done I didn't have anyone close to
me anymore because he had isolated me
from everyone I didn't even want to tag
like I feel like I'm even shrinking
while I talk about this yeah I didn't
even want to text anybody because I felt
like everyone was done with me but that
wasn't true I had ice he had isolated me
from everyone and so I literally went on
Facebook I was like 23 and like I needed
help so badly and I literally was like
I'm done I'm tired of getting cheated on
I'm tired of getting called the n-word
I'm tired I like I said like I'm tired
getting slap something but I really only
gotten slapped once like I don't know
and that's enough well true but
so I went really publishing it and at
the end of it I said please everyone
help me do not let me go back into this
relationship and like I had to oh my god
I'm finally crying on the five guys I'm
super glad to do I like I feel like it
was so it was so bad and like some
people didn't even know who he was
I never said his name I didn't like tag
[ __ ] or anything like that but I
didn't I felt like I didn't have anyone
to turn to and so I had to ask for
people's help
- almost guilt me and shame me into not
getting back with this guy and holy [ __ ]
like you don't have to be crazy and put
it on Facebook but you can tell tell
everyone around you tell everyone around
you so that you you don't go behind the
strength it's like an addiction it's
like you're announcing your addiction
you know like when you're like I'm my
name is Jessica and I'm an alcoholic
like now you can get that home but yeah
it's yeah I can't
I forgot that there's that part of that
shame where you're putting up with this
abuse and you I don't know I I needed I
needed I really needed help I really
really needed help and like if you also
feel like you're hiding this abuse
that's happening to you you have to tell
people because the shame and
embarrassment of going back will keep
you from going back yeah yeah that's
true
first crier good for you like and I and
I actually had a friend pretty recently
a bit she'd been seeing a guy for three
weeks and she was like well we keep
arguing I was like [ __ ] it's been three
weeks and I asked her not a good sign
why were they arguing about she showed
me the text I said you need to run yeah
hey you need to run and B you need to
tell people because your friends will
keep you from going back yeah because
there's like this just this shame that
you feel if you get back with them that
everyone knows everyone knows that
you're [ __ ] stupid yeah and sometimes
you have to do that to protect yourself
I think just to touch up on that like
being the friend because just hearing
you talk
like that like breaks my heart a little
bit because we as the friends can get a
little bit like you know like like a
lack of patience and be like just
[ __ ] leave um yeah stupid but at the
end of the day I think it's so important
if you have a friend who's going through
that like let her know that she
supported you know because when I like
when I've had that friend and I tell her
like I have never said anything behind
your back that I will not say to you I
don't think you should be with him but
I'm still for here for you when and if
she hits the fan yeah and you don't tell
them which you will hit the fan but you
just stay there and you don't tell them
like oh see I told you like no all you
got to do as a friend is be there for
that for that person and yeah I got your
back like you're not alone because no
matter how far away that person takes
you and you get like distracted and
pulled away from the ones you love like
your core group your girlfriends or what
whoever you have is gonna be there for
you and you should always know that
right yeah well some people don't maybe
feel that because and I'm watching this
show which is completely unrelated but
it made me think of that is like if
you're that girl that like when as soon
as I get in a relationship they kind of
just like abandon a friend and do that
yeah like and then it once it's over
then you're afraid because you've kind
of abandoned them and you've grown apart
from them and so now you're like well I
guess I just got to get back together
with my ex because like everyone else
has gone now so I feel like as women and
and men and fellow just humans like we
should be a little bit more accepting of
like okay she kind of disappeared for
like a year six months or whatever but
like I come back let's just be a little
bit more open to like cuz we know it's
hormones that got them in that situation
in the first place like they didn't mean
it but like we all need that support
system - so like still having an open
arm for your friend when they get out of
something because what if it was
actually super abusive and like yeah
being there as a friend like even though
they abandoned you could actually like
save their life or something like you
don't really know until you really know
so I feel like maybe everyone has had
that friend before I bet like they go
into a relationship they disappear jon's
and then when you guys reconnect she's
like girl I got some [ __ ] to tell you
and it's heavy it's so heavy I remember
working one time I worked at a TGI
Fridays
my best friend I hadn't spoken to her in
five or six months and she said hey can
you come outside and I was like I can't
I'm working right now and she came in
and he had dumped soda all over her yeah
like he had just like dumped soda all
over her and she like had left his house
and drove straight over to my job and I
felt so horrible that at first I was
like oh I can't come out because I felt
like she had abandoned me and then I
realized no she was being abused
you don't know what they're going
through you you gotta like be there for
your friends with open arms because
sometimes rather than always throwing
the advice they just want you to be
there okay
well speaking of needing someone to talk
to yeah we have we have a very permanent
sponsor for this this week we have
talked space which is an online therapy
product here they give you a convenient
and affordable and a convenient and
affordable way to improve your mental
health they'll pair you with one of
5,000 over 5,000 licensed therapists
based on your needs and preferences
connect with your therapist via text
audio picture or video messages the same
day you match your therapist will give
you will message you daily five days a
week no office trips or appointments to
schedule and this is a very affordable
option they give you a month of any time
access for the price of only one
in-person therapy session and it's also
secure talk space encrypts and protects
your information using Bank level
security technology safe it's also very
private confidential support of a
dedicated therapist from the privacy of
your device anywhere at any time
we all need help navigating life's ups
and downs talk space offers the support
you need at an affordable price our
listeners can get $100 off their first
month by using code b-tch at talk space
calm match with a therapist for only a
fraction of the price of traditional
therapy at talk space calm or download
the app make sure to use a code b-tch
and get $100 off your first month again
that's talk space calm and use a code
the promo code b-tch
me that did y'all know that you don't
have to go to the dentist and get
orthodontist and get metal braces
anymore yeah from the comfort of your
own home candid we'll send you a whole
kit to create a mold of your mouth and
start getting clear aligners and y'all
clear aligners work I don't know if
anyone else was kind of skeptical I was
like how how they do it I was like you
gonna work actually when you're doing it
at home it's like oh don't you need to
go to an office for this how and it's
significantly cheaper it doesn't require
insurance take a mold of your mouth and
your teeth slowly start to shift candid
can fix most dental yeah
like most orthodontic yeah and treatment
could just take only six months on
average that's pretty fast to fix your
teeth go ahead girl get that photo ready
smile candidate aligners help straighten
your teeth faster than traditional wire
braces treatment just takes six months
um an experience where the dontist in
your state creates a custom treatment
plan they send you the whole 3d preview
so you can see how your teeth are gonna
look after you're done and I think
that's the most exciting part it is
actually it change you look at your
smile and you're like I don't really
like this but you don't know what's
possible so say the 3d scan before they
even come in is really really exciting
they're comfortable removable and
completely invisible they ship them
directly to you and they cost sixty five
percent less than braces I'm 27 and I
did not want to get metal braces again I
had them when I was younger but my teeth
started shifting and had to do what I
had to do completely invisible and also
with each aligner purchase candid candid
donates $25 to smile trained who brings
safe a hundred percent free cleft lip
and palate treatments to children all
around this nice look ya'll I'm gonna
have a photo already smile by the
holidays and you can to go to candid
co.com slash b tch and use code b tch to
get $75 off that's candid co.com slash b
tch code b tch for $75 off
candid co.com slash b tch enter code b
tch awesome thank you
if y'all are skeptical I'm gonna be
posting my results when I'm done with
treatment in February
same girl so where were we at back to
talking about getting bail and crying I
got you okay so do you want daddy issues
yeah what would cause someone to not be
able to just let it go daddy issues if
we knew like guys the first time I've
really been able to light a relationship
go with such ease so I'm trying to
figure out how I can did like determine
the difference between that and all of
these other ones that were so honestly I
really think it matters on your maturity
level and the fact that like you know
you've been through so much in your life
you've already it's because of the fact
that you've been through so much you've
already recognized what you need what
you don't need the signs like everything
that like all everything that you have
been through that's what I'm saying like
guys no matter what you're going through
the universe throws things at you that
it knows that this is what you need it
was hair you to be stronger to grow and
be more mature at the end of it because
like what you've been going through just
like this last relationship it really
you grew so much out of it and that's
why it was so easy for you to just be
like oh you know what I've reached this
level in my life that I know that this
is just not what I need and this is not
what you need Jo and you know what this
is beautiful we can split and but I
wonder though like say I date a new guy
and I get I become extremely infatuated
and then we break up and like will that
young version of me who was just like oh
my god I need him in my like he's not
gonna come back like now it's kind of
scary to me you like how am i so
emotionally stable right now will that
last or like I think it only happens
when someone triggers what's not fixed
there we go there it is yes my theory my
theory is you and Jo we're gonna use
them as an example but everybody can put
them to their ownselves yeah you and Jo
are both very mature and you guys were
post like
I think we've kind of got into the
station that we needed to in our life
like life is kind of like a train
station train station you've gotten here
you guys are like alright we get off
here like we we've learned what we
needed to learn we're separating our own
way but if you for some reason find some
find someone that triggers you in the
right way in the things that you haven't
fixed within yourself we all have an
inner child and what that inner child
asks for if you meet someone that has
the same issues as you and you guys get
into the same toxic patterns then it's
when it can get ugly because what if you
find someone you're like I love him I
love him I love him but he's a cheater
right and you're like I can change him
you know and you for some reason you
find someone who's not as mature as Joe
and you think to yourself [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] that I end up here after being in
such a healthy relationship you know
because how like I think the difference
isn't learning what you want versus what
you need right you know once you learn
the difference between those two like I
want that toxicity I want that
excitement I want that hot act that's
true it's fine I kind of do still want
that easy to let it go cuz we didn't
really have that like you know there was
no more passion there was no more firing
to pull push and pull like it was like
okay we're good now but I'm like yeah I
like feel part of me like once like that
oh my god but I don't want to be in a
relationship to take over my life like
that again I don't want to do that
that's very scary for me you just have
to learn a new type of partnership
because in my first relationship my
first two very three first were
incredibly toxic with toxic people that
I feel like the first one really preyed
on me he knew that I was small and
insecure and damn I just went somewhere
in my head what were we talking about
the files are unpacking I was like damn
I'm like one dumb [ __ ]
like because you to hoe I mean but I
think we we get taught that toxicity we
get taught yes means I love you yeah you
know and I was taught that on repeat in
friendships in relationships
I I have no I don't know if I personally
had something that attracted toxic
people to me
because they knew that I was sensitive
and they could get something out of me
it's like they stole my energy and my
passion I don't know if that was just if
it's me or if life was like I'm gonna
give you all of these lessons to give
you debt room give you understand yeah
and I try to just take it as the second
but now as an adult I get into this
relationship with this amazing man and I
tried to turn it into that toxicity that
I knew feel that I I tried because it
was what I knew I was like this is how I
love this is how I love and he was like
don't do that I love you and I was like
what do you mean this is how I mean like
not verbally but Thomas what you change
was there's no problems here what are
you doing yeah and so I then I kind of
was like whoa I love him these dates are
amazing I have great conversation with
them and then I sat back and I learned
how to love as a partner and how to be
in love with it as a partnership and
having a companion companion that is my
best friend that lifts me up he fulfills
me by letting me go off and do my own
thing and you know be my authentic self
and grow while he grows himself but we
inspire each other everyday and it's
this new love that I never experienced
so I didn't know how to seek it
yeah and if things don't work out
between us I will always seek this exact
type of relationship because to me it's
like true of yeah that's beautiful but
yeah I only knew toxic love for many
many years and you and there's I think
there's multiple types of love yeah and
I think you have to find the right
person to teach you how to love the way
you want to be loved and the way that
you can love someone else but toxic love
that push and pull that we hate each
other we fight and we get back together
some people perceive that as love you
know they
we can have the worst argument and then
make it through there they think that's
love and like that happening every week
is not love yeah I think there's people
who don't even know that a secure love
and a love that doesn't fight and I love
that just like stalks exist yeah like to
them it's like girl you can probably
hear some of the things out like I'm
sure people have something to you guys's
dm's like I need help I have no one else
to turn to and they say like I'm in this
relationship where he's doing this this
this not and I don't know what to do you
know like it's so clear from the outside
what I do it's like yeah when you're in
it it doesn't make sense to you you know
and it was so beautiful when you touched
on like I was in all these toxic
relationships and this person came to
fix it now I think yeah I think that all
of us like because we don't want to give
the message of like oh you have to wait
for someone to come and fix it I think
we can say you should seek out that
relationship that is pure and if you
find if you find something that is not
that you should leave that yeah you
shouldn't wait until they get so bad
where you're like I don't know what to
do anymore I can't breathe so you even
being aware of like I don't want to go
back in to a point where I'm like
push-pull hot cold he loves me he
doesn't let me down
you don't want that so as soon as you
start to see those signs you're like you
know what bye ya know I need to trust
myself that I won't yeah because you've
made that very before and you know
better now yeah you will settle for what
you think you deserve that's true yeah
yeah you know and then what you're
saying to Stacy where you're like oh you
know you have to you have to know in
yourself that you can go out there and
seek that like I don't know I've
recently been really like opening my
eyes to the whole idea of like it all
starts from within like if you literally
learn how to love yourself and have a
relationship with yourself and create
that happiness with yourself you won't
be so dependent on placing that
responsibility on outside forces yeah
which will literally make you depressed
because no one's ever gonna fulfill that
the way you need it to be fulfilled
because you're gonna fulfill that within
yourself
yes [ __ ] yeah
she's talking like she's in church but
it's always going home I just so happy
that to be surrounded by women who
understand that and I'm so grateful that
people have that you know what I mean
like I didn't grow up with women like
you guys like I didn't grow up watching
the stuff I had to go through so much
[ __ ] to learn these things I'd to pay
for therapy to learn these things y'all
get this [ __ ] for free like you should
go to her Channel and listen to a while
but I'll be talking the same [ __ ] on my
yeah like I just think it's really cool
because even from when I first met you
two if you've come such a long way like
it even shows in your face you know so
to hear talk like this yeah I'm like
[ __ ] yeah dude I'm so proud of you you
know and it's crazy because you see
people and you like I see you and I'm
like cool girl you're like just in the
middle like you're gonna keep pushing
watch like 20 20 be careful y'all like I
don't know what Stacy talks to me look
the first time I met Stacy I was like
mom she's gonna be handing me my
one-year token I don't know like good
job though you've come so far the bass
token filling up my cart with my ass
pocket jewelry wearing it all that's one
point to like I think a lot of girls
maybe like in your high school if
everyone kind of acts the same and you
don't you don't have like like smart
people around you it's like if
everyone's doing the whole like oh we're
gonna break up and get back together and
it's wild and crazy but this is just
what we do like you like if you're in
like a small town kind of thing you know
like you don't have any good role models
like you're gonna kind of start doing
what everyone else is doing and you know
what's crazy cuz that just like sparked
a memory miles have opened yeah it's
opened it's crazy because I remember in
my friend group I was the I was like the
last girl to get a
a boyfriend to like ever just even even
have my first kiss like I was like the
last one in my friend group and I
remember seeing like some of my closest
friends and they would have these
boyfriends and they'd like I'd be
sleeping over their house and they're
talking to their boyfriends and they're
fighting tell me why little tip you
wanted it wanted that yeah like I wanted
that for some reason and I felt like
that's what made me feel important or
like yeah very drama yeah it's like oh
my god she fainted she's pregnant yeah
at seven that's what it is because I
really did feel like oh my god they have
some drama there I'm like oh tell me
cheese man I want to be a part of that
too like I want to have a boyfriend to
be like oh my god he's breaking my heart
again Wow oh my god it's so funny and
you you just feel that maybe it's anger
maybe it's sadness but either way it's
an intense feeling and really yeah we
love that because I mean like think
about it you go day-to-day when you're
just say you're at work at your 9 to 5
if nobody's bothering you if she's just
going you literally almost don't really
feel and you're monotone for hours and
hours and hours but then when you have
this person that gives you something
whether it's a high or a low it's kinda
it's a little addictive you know I kept
thinking right now as you were talking
and I like so I only had examples of if
someone's giving you attention it's
because it's negative attention but
those are the only examples that I was
exposed to like even in relationships
within my family like like I said with
my friends and stuff and even like my
own parents like I never actually
witnessed like a healthy loving
relationship that were they do to people
actually respected each other and like I
and yeah like the novellas that didn't
exist so I think that's the reason why
and like at home like I didn't really
receive a lot of attention so I was like
well maybe I could get attention in a
toxic relationship like that's maybe
where I'm gonna find it so yeah
I don't know like that young TIF was
really twisted but I don't blame her it
wasn't her fault yeah you know one thing
I noticed um I was watching the show and
god I've been trying to think of the
name of it but I can't remember it but
the show goes through this relationship
and you really start to fall in love
with this couple right so you get so
invested over the series in this couple
and then you start to see them break up
like things go bad and everything like
are they gonna get back together are
they not and the whole time I'm just
thinking like from the outside I can see
this story of this relationship and it's
like oh if only they just did this
different or if only like this thing
just happened then they could fix it and
like I wanted so badly for the the
characters in this story to get back
together because I'm like look at where
this started and then where it is now
there was just a couple wrong turns like
you guys can fix it and I'm wondering if
a lot of people are thinking like oh
this really isn't a toxic relationship
there's really nothing bad like we we
could just fix it like I don't want to
be a failure like that you and Joe know
Oh period everyone girl I'm just no but
just like watching like watching this
show made me think like for a lot of us
or something no it's something else it's
like it's just like a guy in a girl like
that's kind of like the whole storyline
but I'm just thinking like I wonder if a
lot of people really just try to get
back because all they're just thinking
there's no beginning and you're like oh
I just made this one mistake here this
one mistake there but how all of a
sudden did we get from this beautiful
loving relationship to this distant
relationship like let's get back
together because we were here at one
point like we can do it again but it's
like is so are there circumstances where
like they had this loving relationship
and they just grew distance but maybe
they should get back together and maybe
they can make it like it was in the
beginning like I'm just still trying to
hash out for anyone is there any I think
there a reason to keep it going I know
it's so something I read one time I
think it was like a tumblr quote or
something like that but it was like
dating is basically getting to know one
another until you both have enough of
each other until you find something that
you're like yeah no more I can't do it
you know what I mean like you keep
finding negative things until you're
like okay that's the one thing that I
can deal with but I think what you like
you even saying these things like a lot
of times when we break up with someone
and it's like for a fact we only
remember the good stuff we were meant
sighs the idea of our exes we forget
about things about them we forget the
toxicity we forget you know the little
things so it's very important that when
you're in that stage of like oh I miss
him so much like he was so great he
really was the only one for me
there are so many people in this world
you don't know everyone and to me it's
always been like why am I gonna go with
someone who I already know in know their
faults when I can find someone 100
percent knew like if you didn't like
this this or that about this person you
can find someone who has so many
different things than the last person
you know like to me I always saw dating
as something fun like I can go out there
I can find a finance dude I can do
whatever the hell I want it doesn't even
have to be emotionally attached or I can
emotionally attach myself to this other
person like I often think we see being
single or something negative like I'm
lacking my love when in reality you can
see it as like I'm kind of like job
interviewing a bunch of different people
and I get to pick whoever I want
like I gotta wait for someone to pick me
yeah I get to pick someone new like
there's so many times like yeah it sucks
but instead of looking at it from the
point of like oh I got broken up with
now I don't have anyone you can look at
it that's like well yeah I can go out
there and find what I want what I really
will I think that's definitely where I'm
at right now for sure like I'm excited
to think like oh I don't have to wait
for someone to like me because like in
this in-between moment now for the first
time in my life I have other stuff to
focus on like I have like my friend
group now I have this kind of like
business that we're working on and I'm
not like oh I have to fill my time with
a guy yeah like I don't even have time
for that right now like also and then
when I do I like I'm gonna be real picky
yeah I'm okay with that
I'm just thinking like if there's those
kind of love stories where it's like
everything was kind of beautiful and not
toxic and not terrible but like
something got in the way there master's
program was in another state or you know
this is that and then it's kind of like
they just grew distant but is there ever
a case where people should get back
together and should try to be like
should try to make it work for the
long-term I think it's like well we've
covered like abusive relationship we've
covered I think for you and Jo
it was like we've exhausted everything
and we realized that we are not
compatible yeah even though there was
some passion but then I think there's
also right person wrong time yeah and I
think that's one of the few exceptions
and I've seen it with other people but I
haven't experienced it myself it could
be you guys are incredibly compatible
but the guy is looking at other women
and he doesn't realize how valuable you
are is that really the right person
wrong time
yeah I mean I don't know for charity
wise man or maybe focuses on his career
so much it doesn't realize how much you
know this woman means to have I've seen
that happen and guys guys can make
mistakes too yeah I think we're women
you know vice versa that's the only real
thing I can think of I mean do you guys
can you guys think of a scenario where
like yeah I get back with them I just
think that like if you're young there's
so many other people you can date like
unless you're old already and my mom
just started and that's a thing okay
right so my mom got a divorce 17 years
ago and she just met this man who like
we met her kids we met him and he's so
funny
and like I don't know yeah he could be a
piece of [ __ ] for all I know but he's so
funny and like I like him and I see my
mom excited so if I'm like my mom who
was so in love with my dad and was so
heartbroken when they broke up can find
love and be over here like holding hands
and being cute and going on dates what
the [ __ ] is stopping people our age you
know what's so funny to me is like every
time I was younger and like I saw like
people get divorced or whatever and like
I thought about dating when I'm older
I'm like when I'm 40 am I really gonna
find that 45 year old man attracted like
that's scary to me I'm like no way I'm
gonna find this old man attractive I
know you're 30 looking like hang on to
the one I have now but ya know dude I
see like guys in their 40s and I'm like
hell yeah he's hot yeah so like it's
weird like you kind of get used to have
these these men getting older as you're
getting true yeah but I don't know I had
that weird thing where I was like
there's no way I'm gonna be able to date
someone when they're 40 because they're
gonna be so ugly
you know that's a good point but yeah so
I don't know I just I just didn't know
if there was like because not everyone
knows how to love so there might be
certain circumstances where you just
kind of didn't put the work into your
love and neither of you were really
toxic but you didn't quite know how to
like make the relationship work but time
goes by
maybe you break up six months go by and
you're kind of like you know what we
just didn't try yeah we didn't do
everything we were supposed to do we
didn't speak each other's love languages
or we just didn't put enough time in and
yeah and maybe that's one of the very
few cases where it's worth getting back
with your ex yeah but like if all of
your friends are kind of like excuse me
chase no yeah either way yeah if all of
your friends were like yeah he was cool
I mean I don't know what really happened
with you guys like then maybe that's a
sign you could think about it but if all
of your friends are like girl no because
oh my god and like if I have a friend
that's in a bad relationship or if she's
the problem like your friends will tell
you no yeah well and sometimes there's
times where you are not ready for it and
that I I had a I had a relationship like
that where the guy was great he was
actually really great and I wasn't good
to him saying and I could have been what
people taught us in other relationships
like an app only I had been slapped yeah
that [ __ ] you know like and I feel like
I thought that love was just I felt like
love was not it wasn't real you know and
this guy really really loved me and I
feel like I didn't I feel like I also
didn't deserve his love because it was
so genuine that I think I also destroyed
it yeah you know yeah dude you know what
the [ __ ] the files are open my files are
yeah I think just one last thought to me
is if you feel like you can give it
another chance and you want to give that
person another chance then do it you're
gonna go until you see that one last
thing where you're like [ __ ] no I can't
do it anymore and if there is anyone who
made it work comment down below because
I would love to hear your story cuz I'm
not a believer of getting back with exes
but I would love to be proved wrong
because I am a believer of love so I
would love to hear so a lot of story
like on Reddit and stuff for like a week
we broke up and we got back together
like a year later two years later five
years later and now they're married and
have kids and stuff yeah
it's definitely not impossible yeah but
I think this you like if you're
considering that you just need to
consider what your situation is what are
these circumstances like are they
healthy are they looking like they're
going in the right direction and if you
kind of know it's really not healthy
it's right yeah like do you really want
to make it worse make your shame and
your regret and everything worse like
like how much more are you willing to
put up with just consider it take some
time take a breather before you jump
right back in that's true but yeah but I
guess that that is our episode for today
yeah we just went on a roller coaster
someone cried that means it was a great
uh yeah but we want to give a final
shout out to our sponsors make sure you
go to 3rd love comm slash b tch for 15%
off your first order also for 50% off
your first care of order go to take care
of comm and enter code b tch 50 also get
$100 off your first month of talk space
by using code b TCH at talk space comm
and finally candid go to candid co.com
slash b tch and use code b tch for $75
off fix your smile yeah thanks for
listening thanks everyone is buying me
by E